Any advice for a person with intense
chronic pain that wants to become,
who wants to become a uh,
uh,
oh,
sorry,
it switched on the other we go crayola
sheeps has any advice for a person with
intense chronic pain who wants to
become a contributing member of society,
specifically having the self
discipline to push through pain,
to take care of responsibilities?
Well,
the first thing I would say is that
if you have intense chronic pain,
them,
my heart goes out to you
because that's really awful.
And so I think that you
can cut yourself a break.
I think the fact that you want to become
or continue being a contributing member
to society of society is a
testament to your fortitude.
I guess the first thing I would ask
you is if your pain has been reasonably
managed,
you probably know this,
and I'm not giving you any
medical advice because I can't,
but you might want to note that there
are antidepressants that are quite
effective as longterm pain medications,
and you may already know that,
but if you don't,
then you should check that out because
they're not addictive and they can be a
very effective adjunct.
I would also say that the literature on
chronic pain tends to indicate that more
activity is better than less and that,
and that's partly because when you get
engaged in something that's meaningful,
let's say,
and important to you,
that that activates the
dopaminergic system,
the same system that cocaine activate
sound that can produce a fairly pronounced
analgesic effect.
So I would say everything that you can
do to get yourself occupied with things
that you regard as important
and worthwhile is actually
probably going to help
you manage your pain better.
It looks like inactivity is a bad,
is bad.
Generally speaking,
for chronic pain,
I mean,
obviously that's not the case.
If the sort of activity that you're
engaged in is of the type that will
aggravate an underlying chronic
physiological condition.
But I would say,
uh,
make a plan,
make a daily plan,
make a weekly plan,
um,
make it,
you know,
push yourself a little bit farther than
you can go comfortably on a weekly basis
and see how far you can get any year.
That's because,
what's your choice?
I mean,
you're laying there,
suffering is not preferable
to doing things and suffering,
not generally.
So I would say like more
power to you for trying and,
but,
but also do keep in mind that activity,
meaningful activity is a good analgesic.
So,
um,
Eric Butler says,
sheesh Canadians never get it.
Well,
I didn't know we'd get it.
Sometimes there are,
come on now,
you know,
give us a break.
We're just,
Canadians were freezing
to death half the time.
So,
you know,
we do pretty well given the fact that
every day here in the winter is the
equivalent of a national
catastrophe in the u s so anyways,
um,
Betsy Kirk lender says,
if the second amendment is taken away,
there will be nothing to
protect your freedom of speech.
That is how important it is.
Yes,
well not is certainly the
argument that people who are,
um,
motivated to protect the
second amendment make.
And I'm not going to oppose that.
So.